hi there my name is canelo marwah i'm a
graduate student in chicago
and i'm presenting some joint work with
boaz barak from last june
algorithmic limitations for maximum cut
on high growth graphs
so
i'll give a brief overview of the
the problem that we're looking at
and i'll talk about the state of the art
for max cut
on random graphs and then i'll give an
overview of the main technique
which is why we're presenting at this
conference
so what is maximum cut you take a graph
you split it into two parts and you're
trying to maximize the number of edges
between partitions
in the exact case this problem is np
hard
so most algorithms people look at are
approximation algorithms
there's a notable algorithm the gomes
williamson
semi-definite relaxation this is a
classical algorithm and it's optimal
only in the following sense
it's optimal if the unique game's
conjecture is true
if in its approximation ratio what that
means is that
the approximation ratio is the number of
edges that you can cut over the optimal
number of edges
and it's shown in the worst case
that you can cut around 87 percent of
the edges
however i'm actually interested in a
different
kind of metric the metric i'm looking at
is cut fraction
this is just cut as many edges as
possible
and i'll be looking at mostly random
graphs so
in random graphs the maximum cut as n
and the degree grow large is half plus
just a smidge half plus some constant
over square root d or d is the degree
so 87 percent of that is going to be
below a half
so i'm interested in algorithms that
perform well in cut fraction not
necessarily an approximation ratio
also the semi-definite program is not
local and so what does local mean
um let's call an algorithm k local with
respect to some graph if you first label
every vertex iid from some distribution
and then you recompute every vertex's
label using only the radius k
neighborhood of the graph
and the key idea here is that local
algorithms at small k
can't see the whole graph it's a
restricted model of computation
and so
the question here is can local
algorithms perform well
on these problems
they should
uh be limited in some capacity
also
local algorithms aren't just
you know limited to classical algorithms
i'm also interested in quantum
computation
and
the the state of quantum computers at
this time is that we have these nisk
machines and kind of noisy machines
where you can run a few
algorithms and
but you can't run very much every
operation which is like a two-wire
operation
um
is
was adds contributes some noise to the
system and so you can only do so many of
these before you
let noise overwhelms the signal
and so we're modeling this kind of
computation with local quantum
algorithms and in fact for combinatorial
optimization the most popular
uh
quantum algorithm to run in the near
term is the qaoa or
which is an example of a local quantum
algorithm
but the point here is that with these
noisy machines you can't have a very
high circuit depth
and so your computation is restricted
and so the big question the overarching
question here is are these near-term
machines useful for combinatorial
optimization compared to regular
computers
graphic that might
sum up some of this is you have these q
local machines and q local at depth one
is this green line
q local at some constant depth is the
yellow line
and the classical algorithms are the
black line
and the question is you know do the does
the green or the yellow line you know
cross
the black line
and if there's some crossing then there
is some
you know csp where you can solve it
better
on a local quantum
using a local quantum algorithm which
you could theoretically use a quantum
computer in this decade
to solve
but we're not even sure if this happens
so we've named this nisk optimization
advantage we're not sure if this is
possible there's no theory to support it
yet
and we have a couple results maybe
suggesting it might not be possible
there's this blue line i've written here
to the scalable fault tolerant quantum
computers so the quantum computers of
the long term after you have error
correction and low noise
and
you know millions of qubits what can you
do and you can do anything a classical
computer does and you might actually be
able to do more but again we're not sure
about any of that and it won't be
relevant for many years
so what's the state of the art for
maximum cut
so
here i have a line plot and the line
plot is cutting on random graphs in a
random graph again you have half plus
some constant over square root d
that's the cut fraction or the the
percent of edges that you can actually
cut on a random graph
and so
through some a really fascinating
connection to spin glass theory the
pre-c value 0.76 something
is the optimum you can do on a random
graph as n and d grow large and so that
0.76 on the right side is kind of your
your
target
now when the qa was analyzed at its
lowest step this qaoa is the
popular quantum algorithm that is also
local
and at the lowest depth they got to 0.31
and
it's close to 0.31 it's like 1 over 2
square root e or something
but the point is that it was actually
the best known algorithm at least
measured on this metric
and so a big question was wait is the
qaa really successful on this problem
and it turns out in 2019 the answer is
no
and there was a re-analysis of a of a
threshold algorithm that was classical
and again local
and to show that this one local
algorithm also is
gets about 0.33 which is a little better
than the qaoa but the point is the qaa
is not you know special here
and of course you know this is just at
the lowest depth
what about a higher depth so i did some
work last year that
said no it's actually not true at two
either you know the qaoa does better but
so does this threshold algorithm
and so
a question here is like how well does a
quantum algorithm do but also how well
do classical algorithms do
and so we have two results in this in
this
document
the first result is that all one local
algorithms are bounded away from optimal
and so this is using a really cool new
technique of random walks of
correlations
um
this shows that any one local algorithm
quantum or classical
cannot achieve higher than this 0.71
value so it's a non-trivial result it's
kind of weak
and there's probably lots of ways it
could be
extended but it does show a block like
an um
a maximum that you can achieve using one
local algorithm
we also have a result that i won't talk
about in this talk that is a
a polytime classical algorithm that gets
to 0.63
and this is a restatement of some of
some earlier ideas on gaussian waves
and
it's uh has some relationship to the
semi-definite uh programming algorithm
uh but it's actually outdated you know
it doesn't
it doesn't
it's not super important anymore because
as of november
uh
andrea montanari and and collaborators
found
a classical algorithm that's
asymptotically optimal
so actually there is a gap between these
one local algorithms quantum or
classical and the classical algorithm so
there's a classical algorithm that gets
optimal
at least asymptotically
and
this shows that at least for max cut on
random graphs that yellow line in that
figure will never cross the black line
okay so let's i'll give a brief overview
of the main technique which i think is
it's pretty cool
so
the theorem we have is that when the
girth of a graph is at least six
a one local algorithm can output a cut
of expected value half plus c over
square root d
where c is less than some value and it's
1 over square root 2 about 0.71
okay so how do we get this
so
i mentioned before that i'm using
correlations of random blocks
so if you have a random walk on a graph
after you walk let's say s steps
you're going to be some distance away
from the origin and that distance
you know it's probabilistic and
you can get there you know you can
calculate the chance of being distance d
from the origin
so if your distance one away from the
origin
the correlation of labels that are
adjacent
is actually related to the cut the
chance of being cut
because if your labels are different
then you'll be in different partitions
and the edge will be cut
if your labels are the same you'll be in
the same partition so you won't be cut
so the distance one correlation is
actually
very
it has a
really
simple connection to the cut fraction
and
if you have a correlation at some
distance that's large over 2k
um for a k local algorithm then you'll
be outside of the light cone so to speak
of this k local algorithm and so there
can't be any correlation by the
definition of a local algorithm
and this definition of local algorithm
has really nothing to do with classical
or quantum just the idea of locality
and so any results we prove using these
methods
are going to be
true for quantum and for classical
algorithms
so first we relate like uh you know
we're going to look at one local
algorithms and so three-step walks if
you you know let's look at a three-step
random walk
if you walk three random steps you're
either gonna be distance one or distance
three away
and if your distance one away it's like
you took a one-step random walk but if
your distance three-way there's no
correlation for at least for one local
algorithm you're outside of the light
cone
and so you can relate the you know the
chance of correlation
uh from a three-step random walk to the
chance of correlation from a one-step
random walk because in both
examples there's only one contribution
from distance one away
so this is kind of like the key point
here that you can relate
both
you know walks that travel too far and
you have zero correlation and walks that
travel really close
and distance one means that's the kind
of the
thing we're looking for
so from here we use koshi swartz and we
can say that when you look when you
random walk let's say
four times
it's as if you apply the adjacency
matrix four times
because you're randomly going to a
neighbor which you know does involve
backtracking
and so because you know in this form you
can you can use a cushy schwartz to say
the chance of walking four steps
is going to be at least as big as
you know
you know the correlation at four steps
is going to be at least as big as
walking two steps squared or walking one
step to the fourth
and you can use this inequality to
relate you know two-step to four-step
random walks to one-step random walks
and so putting all this together you're
able to bound
the expected correlation of a one-step
random walk which is just a distance one
you know that's just looking at
neighbors
which
the cut fraction is exactly related to
this value this two over square root d
becomes you know the c becomes one over
square root
two so hopefully this was an overview of
how you can use correlations of random
walks to bound things about local
algorithms
because when you're very close
that's the value you're seeking and when
you're very far you know the correlation
is zero
unfortunately we weren't able to
generalize this
to higher locality with you know and
still get non-trivial bounds but it's
possible that related problems we can
use this technique and
still find out something new about local
algorithms
okay so what's next so so on max cut you
know the overarching question that at
least i've been after is do classical
algorithms outperform all quantum local
algorithms and for max cut on random
graphs asymptotically the answer is yes
by the montsonari paper
but we don't know let's say on graphs of
large but finite girth
or let's say a constant depth local
algorithm that's classical versus a
constant depth quantum algorithm
that's local also
and we also you know there's kind of a
bigger question here is is
quantum computing useful for
combinatorial optimization and i think
there's some real theoretical doubts
that there's no valid like there's no
proven
area
that shows that quantum computing even
in its fault tolerant way
is better for combinatorial optimization
than classical computing
and so not only is this may not be
useful in the near term this may not be
of a great direction for quantum
computers to look at
and so if we're spending a lot of money
thinking about quantum computing for
optimization maybe it's best to put that
money somewhere else
so with that thanks uh i'm at uchicago
now and you can visit my website
um one other thing i wanted to mention
is we put a summary of this work on the
archive wiki which is like a place you
can put summaries and notes of the
papers you read you can explore by topic
you can look at a bunch of papers about
the qaoa
i'm looking for contributors i
started the site last year
feel free to email me about it
and thanks